الينا من عمان اللواء فايز الدويري الخبير
العسكري والاستراتيجي مرحبا بك لواء فايز
اذا هدنه لمده 24 ساعه دخلت حيز التنفيذ
مع تسجيل خروقات هل كنت تتوقع مثل هكذا
خروقات بالنظر الى طبيعه المعركه
نعم الخروقات متوقعه من الجانبين لماذا
لان مفهوم القياده والسيطره الشامل من قبل
قياده الاطراف المتنازعه من الصعوبه
اسقاطها بصوره دقيقه على الجماعات
المتقاتله في المستويات الدنيا وبالتالي
عندما يتخذ السياسي قراره
القبول بهدن انسانيه عليه ان يترجم ذلك من
خلال منظومه القياده والسيطره ولكن في ظل
قطع
شبكه النت عن قوات الدعم السريع في ظل
تحالف منظومه الاتصالات وليس
وتقييم دون الجيد في معظم الحالات سيكون
كنت اتوقع ان يكون هناك خروقات حتى اكثر
مما حدث وبالدال الخروقات الان اعتبرها في
مستوى مقبول في ظل هكذا هكذا ظرف
هذه الخروقات مرتبطه بالنوايا لدى قياده
الجهتين
دعيني اقول النوايا او الاجراءات وهي اكثر
اكثر تاثيرا من النوايا ان هذه الهدنه في
غلاف الخارجي انساني من اجل
ترميم الواقع المجتمعي المتضرر ولكن من
المؤكد ان كلا الجانبين
سيوظفها بصوره دقيقه لاعاده ترتيب اوراقه
من اجل بعد انقضاء الهدنه ستعود
الاشتباكات والاقتتال وكل جانب يحاول خلال
هذه الفتره ان يتجنب الاخطاء السابقه يعزز
مواقعه وبالتالي هذه الهدنه توظف في بعدين
في البعد العمليات من اجل الاعداء الاعداد
لما هو قادم وتلافي الاخطاء وفي البعد
الانساني من اجل الواقع المجتمع البائس
والتقارير السابقه اشارت الى ذلك الواقع
طيب لوفاه كيف سيتم ترتيب هذه الاوراق
التي تتحدث عنها بالنظر الى مارست اليه
خريطه السيطره الميدانيه بين الطرفين
يعني لا يوجد سيطره ميداني واضح حتى اكون
دقيقا لماذا لانه لا يوجد مصدر محايد يقدم
المعلومه التي يعتد بها ويمكن البناء
عليها نحن
كمحللين ومتابعين كما هي العمليات تدور
يدور الجميع في حلقه مفرغه لماذا لانه
يصدر يصدر بيان من قبل الجيش السوداني
يقابله في في غضون دقائق بيان معارض
بالمطلق السيطره على
المطار استعاده السيطره من المطار
الان محاصره القصر الرئاسي لا هناك هجوم
على القصر الرئاسي وقصف بالطائرات فنحن
امام موقف رمادي غير غير واضح لكن بدا لي
خيط محدد اقول ان قياده الرد السريع بدات
تثبت في بوصله العمليات بصوره واضحه ماذا
اقصد بذلك حددت مراكز الثقل لدى الجيش
السوداني وتتلخص في المواقع الاستراتيجيه
في مدينه الخرطوم القصر الرئاسي وقياده
القوات وبالتالي تحاول ان تهاجمها
باستمرار لترسل رساله انك انت غير قادر
على فك الحصار عن القصر الجمهوري وغير
قادر على فك الحصار عن القياده العامه
للجيش النقطه الثانيه او مركز الثقل
الثاني تميزك بالطائرات ساقوم بمهاجمه
المطارات وسالحق الاضرار الكبيره وعرضت
الصور لاربعه مطارات من مروي الى الاوبيض
الى مطار الخرطوم الى غير الى غير ذلك
وصور الطائرات المتضرره اذا دعيني اقول
اتجاه العمليات من الجانب قوات الرد
السريع بدا يتضح شيئا فشيئا لانه مع مراكز
الثقل للجانب المقابل ما هو رد فعل الجيش
السوداني هذا ما يمكن قراءته اذا ما تجدد
القتال بعد انتهاء الهدن الانسانيه شكرا
جزيلا لك اللواء فايز الدويري الخبير
العسكري والاستراتيجي ضيفنا من عمان